Nick Cannon gets candid with Amber Rose
about his divorce from ex Mariah Carey
you tell me your worst breakup story
because I just sighed it's when people
are misleading and devious yeah and the
lying like that's it that's the thing
that hurts more
Nick stop by the amboro show on Friday
to dish on his worst breakup and
co-parenting with the pop diva
are you Mariah still really cool
absolutely I speak to her every single
day matter of fact I've got leave here
and go pick up the kids
so even if a break-up occurs that
doesn't mean the child should suffer if
anything the child and he didn't go into
detail about his divorce drama but Nick
had no filter on the vh1 show when it
came to sex talk the rapper shared how
he made love to me me while playing her
hit song hero in the background that was
some serious love man if you make it
love to hear and then a hero comes along
all jokes aside the comedian says he's
not ready to get back in the dating
scene in fact cannon says he's still
broken after his split from Mariah